habits are one of the phrases i'd like
to use is that pretty much any of the
results in your life are a lagging
measure of your habits
your brain is always developing habits
so it's it's happening whether you want
it to happen or not
and the question is can you take control
of the process i think that the more
sustainable strategy the more reliable
strategy
is to scale it down to the first two
minutes focus on that
establish it master the art of showing
up and then
go from there
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best james clear and my take on his top
10 rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one prioritize
long-term rewards if you take a bad
habit or an unhealthy habit like
uh eating a doughnut or something the
immediate outcome
is favorable it's sugary it's tasty it's
enjoyable in the moment that's how it
serves you
that's the reason why you repeat it the
ultimate outcome if you repeat that
every day for the next three months or a
year or whatever is you end up gaining
weight or you're less healthy or so on
for good habits it's often the reverse
right like sometimes
uh you know the benefit of going to the
gym in many people's eyes is
the immediate outcome is unfavorable
sweat i have to work it's effortful it's
hard and sacrifice
i don't get to watch tv i got to go
there instead um
so the immediate outcome is unfavorable
the ultimate outcome if you repeat that
habit for two months or a year or
whatever
is you're fit and healthy and this is
one of the key challenges
of building good habits and breaking bad
ones is figuring out ways to
take the long-term consequences of your
good habits or of your bad habits and
pull them into the present moment so you
feel a little bit of the pain right now
so it serves you less and to take the
long-term rewards
of your good habits and pull those into
the present moment so it feels good
this is one reason why you know it's
great to choose like what's the best
form of exercise well maybe it's about
the one that you enjoy because if it
feels good in the moment
now it serves you and you have a reason
to repeat it rule number two
develop better solutions your brain is
always developing habits so it's it's
happening whether you want it to happen
or not
and the question is can you take control
of the process and
uh in a lot of ways the fact that we
have these mindless automatic behaviors
it's a pretty good system that evolution
has designed i mean if you think about
it from a very high level
your through as you go throughout life
you are facing problems
and some of those problems are big
problems and some of them are really
small ones like you need to tie your
shoe
and your brain whenever you come across
a solution
to the problem that you're facing and
you repeat it again and again your brain
starts to automate that so you know you
tie your shoe once and
the first time it takes some effort and
and so on but then you do it 50 or 100
or 200 times and pretty soon you can tie
your shoes while having a conversation
or thinking about something else or
whatever
and this is sort of the role that habits
play in our lives is that they
are these mental shortcuts these kind of
automatic scripts that you can just play
whenever the situation
or the context is right and they free up
cognitive resources to focus your
attention elsewhere
and so that's a really good system uh
overall it's
we use it all day long without thinking
about it but occasionally
it can serve us poorly because you know
so let's
let's say you come home from work and
you feel stressed and exhausted
and that's a problem that needs to have
some kind of solution
so for one person maybe they learn that
if i play video games for an hour i'm no
longer stressed and exhausted
for another person maybe learn if i
smoke a cigarette i reduce stress for a
third person maybe it's meditating for
10 minutes for fourth person maybe they
run
for a half hour and the point here is
that different solutions
can cause that can solve the same
recurring problems throughout life
and so your original habit is not
necessarily the optimal habit
for solving whatever the situations are
that you come across in your life the
problems that you face day in and day
out
and so if you can it becomes more about
designing
a better solution uh to those to those
problems
and that's really that's where my focus
is is like all right we're building
habits anyway
how can we develop better solutions to
the recurring problems in our life
rule number three you can find
examples of people who flip a switch and
transform their lives or have an
epiphany and do it overnight
but i think that it's rare i think that
the more sustainable strategy the more
reliable strategy
is to scale it down to the first two
minutes focus on that
establish it master the art of showing
up and then
go from there so really you should like
usually when people think about building
better habits they optimize for the
finish line right it's like
how much weight do i need to lose how
much money do i need to make you know
how when can i finish this book
it's all focused on the result but i
think instead if you optimize for the
starting line
make it as easy as possible to start
scale it down
organize your environment so all that
stuff is set up this is another strategy
for making it easy which is that
you can prime your environment to make
the future action easier right like if
you
chop up a bunch of vegetables and fruit
on sunday it's now easier to have a
healthy snack during the week
if you set your workout clothes out the
night before it's now easier to get into
the workout the next day
but doing all that stuff to make it easy
to show up
that is probably the more important
piece early on rule number four
find behaviors that serve you in order
to change
behavior design it in any meaningful way
you need to be aware of it first
but usually when people become aware of
their habits or think about them you
know like you might
smoke or bite your nails or something on
autopilot but then if you start to think
about it well you feel guilty about it
you know you start to judge yourself
as soon as you start to judge yourself
then you're not in a great position
to change because you what ends up
happening a lot of the time this has
happened actually with a couple
campaigns
that have tried to scare smokers into
not smoking by showing them pictures of
blackened lungs
or scare obese people into not eating as
much by talking about the
the detriments of being overweight what
happens is people get really anxious and
stressed
they feel guilty and worried and then
they resort amplify
they resort to their preferred habit for
dealing with that which means they end
up smoking more eating more or whatever
so uh yes i think there is a benefit to
looking at it in an unemotional
forensic way and one way to do that
is to say there are no good or bad
habits there are just behaviors that
serve you in a particular way
and the goal is to try to find a
behavior that
serves you in a better way also if you
want to have more self-confidence and
self-belief i've designed a special
free training to help you get it where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you
a link to an unlisted video to your
email
to every day shift your confidence and
self-belief forward
the science says it can take up to 254
days
of consecutive action to make a habit
stick
and i want you to get the habit of
self-confidence and self-belief
the link to join absolutely for free is
in the description below
you can out-work anybody how badass they
are
self-discipline comes from the self it
comes from you
if you are trying to make high level
decisions focus
on time consuming high priority projects
rule number five restructure your
environment i'll give you an example of
a good habit and a bad habit so
for good habits you want the physical
environment to make it obvious and easy
for you to do the behavior
you know so like i um like have a
pull-up bar in your room exactly trying
to do 100 pull-ups a day right like have
it hanging over your door
as opposed to even if you had one but it
was in the closet because you just half
the time you wouldn't
take it out or it's at the gym upstairs
or down the street
no um you know i have a friend who he
wanted to practice uh guitar more and so
he left his guitar in the middle of his
living room
and that just so he'd walk past it a
hundred times a day and becomes much
easier
right bad habits are the same way um so
but in reverse
instead of making it obvious you want to
make it invisible
um you know take like which is just
talking about video games
a lot of people feel like they watch too
much spend too much time watching tv
or playing video games or watching a
screen but if you walk into pretty much
any living room
where do all the couches and chairs face
they all face the television so it's
like what is that room designed
to get you to do turn it on yeah so
you can restructure that environment to
make it less likely that you'll fall
into that habit and there are a variety
of things you could do you could take
the remote control and put it inside
like a drawer so you don't see it
you could put the television behind a
wall unit or cabinet so that it's less
visible
but you could also increase the friction
with the task so you could like
unplug your tv after each use and only
plug it back in if you can say the name
of the show that you want to watch so
you can't like mindlessly pull up
netflix and just find something
or you could take the batteries out of
the remote control so that it's an extra
like five to ten seconds
to turn on and maybe that's enough time
to be like do i really want to watch
something right now
i'm just doing this mindlessly yeah um
if you really want to be extreme don't
have a tv
yes you could get rid of the tv entirely
or take it off the wall and put it in
the closet and only take it out when you
really want to watch something
rule number six build keystone habits is
there such thing as
i guess central habits that can help to
shift and transform
other aspects of your life because
that's something that i've noticed a
little bit
where if i start eating better or if i
start going to the gym every day
it's almost like a domino or ripple
effect where these other habits start to
pick up
naturally because i'm starting to feel
better so like because i've been going
to the gym five days a week
so now when i come home i don't feel
like binging out on junk food i feel
like eating better food
or if i wake up early uh is that
something you've noticed in your
research
yeah sure so there are two ways to
answer this question so the first way is
um what you're describing is often
sometimes called a keystone habit
and the idea is you do one thing and it
like ripples into other areas of your
life
and so for me it's exercise like if i go
to the gym then i get the benefits of
exercise
but i also tend to eat better i like for
some reason i just don't want to waste
it
um i also focus more so i have
sort of that like post workout high
after i after i work out
and then i sleep better because i'm
tired from the workout which means i
wake up the next morning and i have
better energy
and at no point was i trying to build
better sleep habits or energy habits or
focus habits or nutrition habits but all
that kind of just came as a side effect
of doing this one thing of going to the
gym some other common
keystone habits are budgeting sometimes
people say when they pay off debt
you'll then they'll like start to get in
shape or they um you know build but
they're more social and have better
relationships
like there's all kinds of things that
kind of come out of that um
going for a daily walk is a really big
one it's very common one among creators
in particular
there's a book called daily rituals by
mason curie
and he basically just writes down like
what i don't know it's 100 or 150 famous
like creators and scientists and
whatever what their daily routines were
and a lot of them were raging alcoholics
and on amphetamines and all kinds of
other stuff
but the ones who uh were more healthy a
daily habit a daily habit like walking
was a really big part of their routine
visualization is a big one especially
for performers like a comedian or
something they'll often visualize the
same kind of result or professional
athletes
before they step out on the stage or
step out on the court rule number seven
avoid the all or nothing mentality this
is
a real pitfall for a lot of people with
habits is they have this like all or
nothing mentality
they're like start this diet and then
they go binge eat with their friends for
you know like happy hour or something
and then they're like oh well you know
i blew the diet guess i shouldn't even
bother right and
i think that this is um this is a mantra
that i like to keep in mind with habits
i mean the truth is every habit streak
is going to end at some point you know
like when i
when i launched my site i wrote a new
article every monday and thursday for
three years
but then i signed this book deal and i
needed to change that and so that streak
ended and
you've probably had a variety of times
this year where you've done meditation
for
five days in a row or seven days in a
row or twelve days in a row but then at
some point that streak broke
and the key is never miss twice you know
like if you get back on
if you can get back on track quickly
then that's a huge win
um i've seen this in a lot of areas now
as i started to study people who are
like top performers whether it's sports
or
in business but it's it's not that they
make they don't make mistakes
people at the top levels they make
mistakes too but they just get back on
back on track more quickly so
it's almost never the first mistake that
ruins you
it's like the spiral of repeated
mistakes that follows um
i think in the book i have a line
something like missing once is a mistake
missing twice is the start of a new
habit
and what you don't want is to start that
new habit you want to never miss twice
and just get back on track as quickly as
possible
and you can keep that in mind um it
could end up being pretty powerful for
consistency
you know it's like even if you only did
that if you never missed twice if you
did it and then missed and they're like
well i'm not gonna miss twice you did it
again and then you missed and then you'd
do it at least 50
of the time um so anyway yeah i think
that's uh
that says something about your mentality
that you keep coming back to it even
though every now and then it doesn't
work out
rule number eight reward your progress
every behavior
is followed by some kind of outcome it's
just basic cause and effect
um and if the immediate outcome is
favorable is enjoyable you have a reason
to repeat it in the future
it's kind of like doughnuts yeah exactly
right it's like that example
if you if you um if you
feel good if you feel satisfied right
after you do something then it's like
this positive emotional signal and it's
like yeah i should do this again yeah
so you can see this actually business is
a really interesting example with this
there are a lot of products and some of
the most successful products
have some type of immediate satisfaction
that is layered into them
so toothpaste is a very common example
there's no reason a toothpaste needs to
taste like mint
but it does because the minty flavor and
the refreshingness of it and make sure
it gives your mouth this clean feel
it's more satisfying so you have a
reason to do it again in the future
i heard an interesting one recently
about car manufacturers that some of
them are adding a fake
guttural roar to the the car or the
truck when you press the accelerator
because it just adds to the actual
natural sound of the engine so it makes
it more satisfying to step on the gas
and to drive the car so there are a
variety of examples like this but if you
can
add and the key is it needs to be
immediate right
so like this is um in the book i refer
to this as the cardinal rule of behavior
change
which is behaviors that are immediately
rewarded
get repeated behaviors that are
immediately punished get avoided
and it's really about the speed of how
quickly you feel successful
if it feels good you have a reason to do
it again is that why video games
do so well video games are masters at
this they're masters at it so
um they're masters actually at a variety
of of aspects related to habit formation
so one is they're really good at this
immediate satisfaction
there are all kinds of things you're
actually constantly getting feedback in
a video game
even if you're just running you hear the
pitter patter of the steps
it's that's gratifying it's yeah the
jingles of like picking up another
power-up or
um you know seeing a kill or something
like that whatever the game is you're
always getting constant feedback sound
things that are on screen they're really
good at dripping out watching the
the score increase in the top corner
that is immediate feedback
so they have all these different ways of
making you feel satisfied
and when you see that progress you have
a reason to continue in the future
this is one of the one of the most
effective forms of immediate
satisfaction
is progress as soon as you feel progress
you have a reason to continue
it feels really good to see that you're
making headway rule number nine
understand the importance of habits my
publisher
told me uh there's something to the
effect of like we write the books we
need ourselves
and that's uh it's funny because
you know when i write about habits a lot
of people assume that i have my habits
so dialed in because i'm the guy writing
it
right but i'm writing about it to learn
about it you know i'm writing about it
to try to improve
i consider my readers and myself to be
peers
right we're all just kind of
experimenting and operating and working
on stuff
and uh the only difference is i just
share the lessons when i learn them
um so yeah i um i definitely had an
internal desire for that uh and then
there have been a variety of areas in my
life where i've had to implement that
athletics um photography uh writing and
building a business of course
and all of those have been kind of like
test labs
for me to to put the ideas into practice
right so why zero in on this
on habits yeah well
i think that a little bit of it comes
back to what you just mentioned a few
minutes ago
about how important habits are uh i
didn't know this at first
so i was a baseball player for many
years and as any athlete can tell you
there are all kinds of habits that you
have at practice
rituals things like that and i was
benefiting from that um
you know my strength coach would tell me
to do something or my coaches would hold
me accountable to certain habits
and that would help pull the rest of my
life in line you know i always did
better in school when i had sports as
well uh it would like
give me something to anchor my day
around and so
i knew that it was working but i didn't
have a language for it
and so it was only until maybe five
years after my career ended and i
finished graduate school and i started
like looking into this stuff a little
bit more that i started to come across
the science of
habit formation and behavior change and
developed
a language for it and started to write
about it so i kind of
implicitly knew it was important but
didn't discover that the
actual way to write about it until later
now the second thing here though
is that i as i dug into the topic more
i started to like unearth these layers
and realize wow this is actually even
more important than i thought
and this comes back to the point that
you made a few minutes ago which is that
habits are one of the phrases i'd like
to use is that pretty much any of the
results in your life are a lagging
measure of your habits right so your
weight is a lagging measure of your
eating habits your bank account is a
lagging measure of your financial habits
your
clutter is a lagging measure of your
cleaning habits like
the outcomes are just the the
manifestation of the behaviors that
preceded them right um
so you kind of get what you repeat in
that way well that makes sense people
understand that that's important so
that's one reason why habits are
crucial but there's another thing that
habits do
that is even more central even more
important
and that is that your habits are the way
that you embody
a particular identity so every morning
that you make your bed
you embody the habits of you embody the
identity of an organized person someone
who's clean
every time you go to the gym you embody
the identity of someone who is fit
every time you sit down to write a
sentence or a page
you embody the identity of someone who's
a writer and so in that sense
habits are like every action you take is
kind of like a vote
for the type of person that you believe
that you are and as you take these
actions you build up evidence
of a particular identity and pretty soon
your beliefs have something to like root
themselves in it's like man
you know i've showed up at the gym for
four days a week for the last three
months i guess like i'm the type of
person who doesn't miss workouts
um and that i think is the true reason
why habits are so important
once i realized how beliefs and
behaviors are connected
that it's like this two-way street
then i've started to think all right
maybe this is really something not only
does it deliver those external results
the clean room
or the you know bigger bank account but
also
the internal results of shaping your
sense of self-image and what you believe
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is make better choices basically there
are these
little moments throughout the day well
if you depending on what research study
you look at
habits account for 40 to 50 of our daily
behaviors and this is
all the stuff that you're just doing
without even thinking you know tying
your shoes or unplugging the toaster
after each time you use it or whatever
but the true influence of your habits is
even greater than that
because in many ways habits are kind of
like a fork in the road they're like an
entrance ramp on the highway so you do
something mindlessly like you pull your
phone out of your pocket and you don't
even think about it
takes five seconds but after you do that
it shapes the next like 20 minutes of
conscious attention
and choices that you're making so maybe
you browse social media or you respond
to email or you play a video game
but whatever choice you're making it was
already the context was already shaped
by that mindless habit of pulling your
phone out
and so i would refer to that as like a
decisive moment these little automatic
actions
that you do them and then after
30 seconds they've already shaped the
next 20 minutes or the next chunk of
time that's going to come
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get
motivated inspired you have a 35 chance
of following through but when you get
motivated inspired and you create a plan
of action
you have a over 90 percent chance of
following through
and when you share with other people it
jumps to 95
chance your likelihood of following
through and so i want that to be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you i want
to share a little story about the ship
of theseus which is this
ancient greek parable story about this
ship that goes into athens greece and
parks in the dock
and as it's there it's used year after
year some of the boards start to wear
away some of them start to go bad
and so whenever one board is bad they
take the board out and change it and put
a new one in
this process continues for 25 or 30
years until every
board that is on the ship has been
changed out for a new one
and philosophers for centuries have
asked is this the same boat
is this the same thing that was there
before is both entirely the same and
entirely new
and i would say that your habits can be
the same way we often fear
that in order to achieve something new
to become someone new we have to
abandon everything that we are but in
fact that's not how it works change can
happen
plank by plank board by board habit by
habit and gradually
you can become someone new with
consistency and repetition
you can actually change not only your
results but actually your identity
and the reason that this is true is
because the more evidence
that we have for a belief the more
likely we are to believe it
so if you go to church every sunday for
20 years you believe that you are
religious
if you study spanish every thursday
night for 20 minutes you believe that
you are studious the actions that you
take provide
evidence for who you are and it's not
that
habits matter more necessarily on an
individual basis each moment in life
matters but what ends up happening is
that over the broad span of time
things that you do once or twice fade
away and things that you do time after
time day after day week after week
accumulate the bulk of the evidence for
what you believe about yourself
and so every action that you take is
actually a vote
for the type of person that you want to
become if you want to become someone new
then you can take a new action and begin
to accumulate evidence for that identity
for that belief about yourself
and that the more votes that you cast
the more likely you are to win the
election
you don't need to be unanimous you don't
have to be perfect all the time you just
need to have the body
of work right so true change is actually
not behavior change it's not results
change it's not process
change it's identity change the goal is
not to become
the goal is not to read a book it's to
become a reader the goal is not to
write a book or write an article to
become a writer the goal is not to run a
marathon to become
a runner to become a type of person to
develop an identity
and the way to being something or
becoming someone is through doing
something so every time you sit down to
write every time you practice that habit
you are being a writer every time you
play a sport you're being an athlete
every time you practice painting or
music or whatever you're being an artist
your identity emerges out of the habits
that you have
and so here's the secret to this talk
it's not just about getting you to make
small changes it's not just about
putting a book
on your pillow or putting an apple on
the counter it's actually about getting
you to believe something new about
yourself something possible
about yourself and habits are not only
the method
through which we achieve external
measures of success like losing weight
or gaining more
earning more money or meditating and
reducing stress they are also the path
through which we achieve
internal change and actually become
someone new
they're the path through which we forge
the identity that we have
the deepest beliefs we have about
ourselves our sense of self
and so if you can change your habits you
can change your life
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there